[Music]
in making his way downtown news van call
my mom but a month what about the DB gun
down
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's like way off he has nursing white
chicks how dare you the best movie ever
Terry Crews yes Ted Cruz and was it I
love Terry only forgot about that no I
mean the theme song we were singing is
the same song I'm making is way don't
tell yep yeah submitted by chubby taken
his face is chubby my girl's got a
pumpkin for ahead do it was huge
no you're late Larry he's his body is oh
my god what's gonna be his Halloween
costume mayor but you do it you to tell
me you guys are Jack no I don't know yet
there's so many options to show you all
three bears bears oh my god and then
turn your garage into a cave and then
just sit outside during Halloween and
just let me stand there in front of you
and cry just like Gina it's been three
hours dude please what's this
oh man sorry you don't even drink water
how are you crying these many tears it's
all red bull tears bitch's name was
amber what did you say was that when I
pee it's just hard amber oh my god
that's terrible
like a month for its it Regina it's like
the honey with [ __ ] insects in it
already you need a drink water
yeah like ever since that episode came
out my viewers on my stream was like yo
do you know what the [ __ ] they actually
bought me a water dispenser yet - gonna
watch you drink one of these alright
don't think it's alkaline oh how do you
not get UTIs oh no I'm superhuman he
says her pussy's killer that's true even
that urethra and everything everything
it touches all the bacteria like oh no
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this net water dispenser
and I've still yet to buy and water
subscriptions because they were so
concerned waiting for them to buy you a
water Sameera
I could buy some tunes it's a hint but
every stream like every like 30 minutes
or so they're like Gina drink water and
okay [ __ ] mom I got thirsty hearing
about your dish right meets you deserted
ass so a young man was gifted a car
after walking 20 miles to his first day
of work this all does this is well
technically you walked 14 but why did he
choose a job so far away no [ __ ] car
you gotta make money you gotta make
there's no other job opportunities like
one mile away why are you shaming him
I'm not shaming I don't think he was
like what's the furthest away for me to
like inconvenience myself there it is
probably wasn't thinking like that but I
also wasn't thinking he is first place
that hired him no let me tell you this
is a really sweet story so the stories
about Walter Walter okay yeah I like I'm
ready though Walter he was supposed to
start his very first day with the moving
company called bellhops the next morning
but that night his car broke down and so
he has to go they planned it where he
could have drove so he had a car he had
a car so he had someone to give him a
ride but then that ride fell through so
I had midnight that friend I know at
midnight that's when he decided to start
making his way so how many hours did he
walk he walked at least 14 miles when at
4:00 a.m. a police car picked him up
because they were like what the hell
these Jews walking at 4:00 a.m. that's
crazy so they picked up on that sounds
like a normal reasonable time you see
you must be an Irvine or something hold
you over for no reason dude happen in
Alabama that's so nice they're not like
look at his [ __ ] crackhead yeah it's
like he must need it right yeah well
what I'm assuming is that they probably
passed him and then they went somewhere
else and then they came back saw him
again anyway downtown there's like f4
hands were walking all over the place
I mean I'm good downtown grocery in
Newark it's not really about that I'm
just in for me like I wouldn't be like
last weird but if it's like Alabama more
like a smaller city it is kind of weird
yeah yeah that's a serial killer yeah so
then they picked him up he told them
like his whole thing how he's starting
his new job the next morning he has to
be there by 8:00 a.m. oh [ __ ] so then
the cops they were really nice they
ended up taking him to go get breakfast
Oh
Alabama cops are awesome they took him
to a church in the meantime like well it
was time for him to go to the home that
he was supposed to meet the other movers
but then there's other reports saying
that they just drove him directly to the
house so I'm not sure exactly what
happened but the point is he ended up
arriving at the home
ring the doorbell spoke to the woman
that hired this moving company told the
cop everything what he had gone through
she was asking like do you need any food
do you want to rest like you know we
have an extra room upstairs like poems
and then Walter was saying that he
probably spent about like five minutes
telling her like no it's okay really I
just want to get food jobs and then she
just he just passed out no really up
then yeah you just wanted to start
already like start the moving process so
he got there before any of the other
movers and then when the other movers
got there she returned a miss Jenny
Jenny started telling Walter like tell
them tell her everything you just did
like this is amazing I'm like oh my gosh
I can't believe he did this in this so
he started telling other people so she
ended up posting on Facebook this whole
story of Walter and how cool super early
walked all those miles to a hard-worker
yeah and in the fact that he declined
resting and like he just immediately
wanted to start working so then the CEO
of bellhops found out about this and he
decided to do something nice for the kid
oh so first of all this is Walter like
hi Walter got a shirt like that well
make it about Tyco okay baby every day
shape to those cuz some frog whale is a
little dicks it's an anchor suitably my
baby - I'll make it about Casey
take it away from tight blue instead of
red anyways the wave doesn't have a
shirt like that
he's got Wu Tang and [ __ ] Chuck
Norris Jenny I guess they don't have
over in Alabama I'm saying the money to
spend on that the money like that's what
he was like determined to make that's
this first day of work so you know show
you guys a video clip of when he met the
CEO of the Hopf know I bet he regrets
not buying that bicycle you know he
wanted to buy a bicycles I don't [ __ ]
need this [ __ ] and then when he started
walking up [ __ ] about that bicycle
mm-hmm I hate when I do that Jenny and
her post - she also said like imagine
how many times he was telling himself
like I should turn back now I should
like not even I should call in sick I
should whatever not a business in a
Vanessa Carlton the funny thing is like
what if everyone else is like oh my god
that must have been horrible and he's
like man I just wanted to do it
Yeah right like for like youth like he
was determined I was like yeah I just
want to work like I want to get my [ __ ]
done you know like I'm here to work he
really is and then everyone else is like
oh my [ __ ] god you [ __ ] walk
that's crazy
do you need a rest super humble value
yeah that's dope I wanted me to do this
like he was just saying like God put me
on this path for a reason God broke my
car down yeah exactly yeah he was to
teach him a lesson
yeah I have never even been half as
committed to something you're not even
committed to it's true I'm got my roots
done forever now it's an ombre hello
yeah I thought you planned that
thank you thank you very much how does
he know to say no notice [ __ ] so then
Jenny on her Facebook post she also
mentioned that Walter and his mom moved
to Alabama from New Orleans because they
lost her house during Hurricane Katrina
and then that his mom is also diagnosed
with cancer
Jesus this job is super important that
makes so much sense
I have a theory all this walking and
then Jenny they're gonna
Alabama worse cop no I I showed you a
photo of Jenny 10a is with Jenny and the
walking and she has a husband - OH
your theory is uh Jenny I love you Hey
geriatric love is real we don't knows
when all this are not research I love
you Jenny here we go and I heard your
stories fine Sunday morning I just blown
away it's pretty cool artwork every day
bring our customers okay don't make fun
of them you really took it to the next
level it was like some girl like mowing
the lawn next to that there's a weed
whacker
so yeah pression all Oh sounds like yeah
and you're gonna be walking a lot cuz
you can do a lot of don't have shops too
so we as a team kind of got together
last night and we're trying to think
about all right
how can we get Walter good job got
everything you know Muhammad Ali is well
a way to get these arms are driving me
crazy oh this is my car but not I like
it be your car oh and so yeah it's party
Ana's dog today right now I think you
better wait up to part ways with this
interview he does he barely uses it
that's dough yeah kind of car is it you
know be mad you don't be really it'll be
funny as hell
what if his car that broke down was
actually better than the car that here
with Jimmy and all he needed was a
little bit of like like it like a
hundred buck job or some [ __ ] right and
he's like he's like here's the car here
I don't use it anymore
it's my 1993 Honda Civic I know it's not
much but he's like what the [ __ ] and you
open it up and there's like trash that
falls down and there's like a greasy cup
and chance so it was actually a 2014
Ford Escape he says like you've barely
used it so he that's the one car I can't
even picture Ford Escape you know I'm
not you know you name any cards so bad
or whatever I can picture the car I
don't know the image of an escape I
always it in black I don't even know
what it is I never seen a Ford Escape or
maybe I did I just don't recognize
there's no Dodge Caravan boom I know I
see the car if that was me and he gave
me a [ __ ] PT Cruiser I'll be like No
thank you sir 2014 Ford Escape way off
whoa whoa would you drive that Gina okay
Secret Service PT Cruiser a PT loser
thank you decreases anymore a lady bells
both cars were like the fetal alcohol
syndrome of card manufacturing they look
like a monster movie oh yeah and the HHR
terrible well there's Geo Metro Geo
Prizm the Juke it was all Nissan Juke oh
that's just disgusting - yeah sorry
you've offended you in this conversation
almost look like a smart car but yeah so
wheel oh that's me the science me
my office ion-ion but it looked like a
smart car but like a little bit bigger
Fiat yeah Annie Cooper yeah yeah that's
a shot with an Italian flag it's like a
little color with potato he's a little
petite you look like you belong to the
movies part yeah exactly he looks like
he belongs in that car
[Music]
little reporters
there are two principal food systems
Oh
[Music]